foreign
I was the Messiah
for about a week
and for those of you who haven't had the
privilege of being the Messiah I have to
tell you something
it is awesome
imagine you are the person that's going
to save the world
bring peace on Earth and no one knows it
yet but you
I arrived as the second coming my senior
year of college
New Year's Eve 1999. after a night of
partying I came to a stunning conclusion
I was Jesus 2.0
for the next 100 hours I couldn't eat
I couldn't sleep
but I did spend a fair amount of time
preaching my gospel at the Burger King
in Evanston
turns out though and this may be a
disappointment to my supporters that I
was in fact not the Messiah
I was just a 20 year old Midwestern kid
having a manic episode
later diagnosed as a symptom of bipolar
disorder type 1. and it was very much
not awesome
for my family and my friends
and so what exactly is a manic episode
typical symptoms include a lack of sleep
grandiosity Relentless optimism
high-risk behaviors racing speech and
ideas that are seen as delusional
does that remind you of anyone
because it sounds to me like an
entrepreneur having a good day
and in fact it is estimated that three
percent of all of us have bipolar a
staggering number in its own right for
entrepreneurs that number is 11 and at
the intersection hi Mom that's me the
best of both worlds
and it's not just bipolar according to a
study from the University of California
at San Francisco
entrepreneurs also over index in ADHD in
depression and in substance use
and maybe this correlation between
neurodiversity and Innovation shouldn't
surprise us
after all to be an entrepreneur is to
conjure things that aren't real yet
that sort of invention that sort of
vision requires more than a little bit
of magical thinking
a vision that might seem Fantastical to
others at first is later deemed to be
obvious like say flying through the air
in a huge metallic capsule at 30 000
feet and 575 miles an hour
for me that Vision get ready for it was
pants
it's always been pants
okay well not exactly my vision was one
for a world where Brands would be built
internet first
and so in 2007 I co-founded a menswear
e-commerce company called bonobos
now I know what you might be thinking
selling pants online is not that
remarkable of a vision
but in 2007 it was improbable think
about it Amazon was barely focused on
fashion
Apple had only just launched the iPhone
mobile Commerce in the App Store were
just twinkling the eye
Facebook didn't have an ad platform
that's by the way where you acquire
customers for a digital brand and
essential tools for digital storytelling
like Instagram and Tick Tock it didn't
even exist Instagram was three years
away from being created and Tick Tock
was nine years away maybe that was a
good thing at the time
every venture capitalist we pitched
said the same thing
you guys are crazy
which is an interesting word choice if
you think about it in this context
against these odds over the next decade
we went on to raise a hundred million in
venture capital
to sell over a million pairs of pants to
invent an inventory free retail store
and open 60 of those
creating ultimately over 500 jobs the
company was acquired a decade after
founding by the world's largest retailer
by revenues itself in its own process of
digital transformation for over 300
million
building any brand now internet first
is commonplace
it's table Stakes it's obvious
maybe it wasn't so crazy after all
but there was a dark side to this
success
friends and mentors and other Business
Leaders warned me that the
entrepreneurial Journey was filled with
dramatic mood swings highs and lows they
even call startups what
a roller coaster
and so my bipolar disorder was cloaked
not as symptoms of an illness or a
condition but symptoms of a job
I cycled through a couple of mood States
dizzyingly productive periods of
hypomania a misunderstood Moon state
that is a diluted form of mania without
The Telltale psychosis that leads to a
diagnosis of bipolar one but all of the
increased energy and creativity and
ideation in Dua de vivre and burning the
candle at both ends you can get a lot
done when you're hypomanic alternating
with
devastating periods of depression for me
both mild and severe often 50 or 100
days at a time catatonic can't get out
of bed disappearing on the team
unable to go to work
sometimes undesirous of living
in all of it was Amplified by what was
happening at work a gutting co-founder
divorce
a rotating door of executive turnover
maddening inexpensive flights into shiny
new objects and distracting ideas often
driven by hypomania
in a whopping cash flow burn rate that
at times reached five million dollars
a month
it's hard to do actually but but we did
it
and all of it boiled over in 2016. I was
leading a team of 400 people when the
Mania that I hadn't experienced since I
was preaching the gospel at Burger King
when I was 20.
came raging back
in a manic episode at my New York
apartment
I Rose from my bed literally howling at
the moon
convinced I was the president
and Batman
which is actually a high potential
combination if you think about it
and then the darkness really set in I
smashed my fist into a glass window pane
and worst of all I struck my now wife
Manuela
and pushed and kicked her mother Lenny
to the ground as they tried to protect
me
to prevent me from running naked into
the streets of Greenwich Village
when I saw
when I saw Lenny two weeks later
I thought it would be for the last time
and instead she put her hand on my hand
and she said something I'll never forget
in something I hope all of you never
forget
she said Andy this is just like any
chronic physical illness
all you have to do is see your doctor
and take your medication
and if you do
and if Manuela wants to stay with you
then you have my blessing
and I started crying as you might
imagine
and Manuela did Stay With Me
but her love and commitment came with
conditions
it was our Rabbi who told us on our
wedding day that the only unconditional
love on the planet is that between
parent and child which was the
disappointing thing to hear on my
wedding day I thought you know I was
headed for the unconditional love thing
he said all other forms of Love Are
conditioned they are conditioned upon
each of us treating Each Other Well
which requires accountability and
boundaries
conditioned upon an honest and
transparent exchange of information and
feelings which requires disclosure and
feedback
and condition upon each of us
individually doing all in our power to
be well which requires initiative and
self-care
and this is not just in our personal
lives it's also at work
now Manuela and I are married with a
two-year-old
he's
he's not too in that photo he would that
would be a very small two-year-old
and look some days that feels like a
miracle
from where I was
to now it feels like a miracle and while
manuela's love is a miracle in Isaiah's
existence his very existence is a
miracle my getting well was not a
miracle
it was very hard work
and it still is so I've got and I'm
proud to say in Olympic regimen
of mental hygiene and mental Fitness
let me play it to you I see a
psychiatrist two to three times a week
for a 45-minute therapy session now you
would think therapy once a week is
enough but for me I want my doctor to
lay eyes on me every 72 hours so he can
assess my mood I've got five different
medications
that I take one every day and the other
four we titrate up and down depending on
where I am
and then I've got a Relentless focus on
sleep because sleep is for for me
certainly with bipolar a leading or a
lagging indicator of mood and by the way
that might be all of us
and so every morning the first thing I
do is I send a Fitbit sleep report to a
WhatsApp group that includes my doctor
my wife and the three people who have
endured this with me the longest
my mom Usha my dad Charlie and my sister
Monica
here it is
every morning this is my statement of
life and what is it it is a daily
reminder to never forget what's possible
for all of our strengths have shadows
don't they
it doesn't take a lot of brain power to
bring to mind other entrepreneurs
leaders and Visionaries
who have caused Great harm to themselves
and others
even Society at Large
and so what do we do we admire their
strengths we even lionize them as
individuals
but their Shadows we ignore
and we do so at our individual and
Collective peril
I would know
because for 16 years I ignored mine at
Great cost to myself and others
why did I do that because I didn't want
to be bipolar
that's what we say of people who have
bipolar
we don't say someone is cancer
we say they have it
that's a first step
to helping our friends and our loved
ones and our colleagues not by
conflating their illness or condition
with their identity
but by acknowledging it as just a part
of their life story and then helping
them confront it
at work I think therapy should be more
or less mandatory for people who lead
teams
second chances for unethical leaders
should require great consideration
should just straight up no
longer be accommodated
boards need to step up in all of us we
need to raise our hands when we're not
well
and then seek and secure the help we
need
I
have been unbelievably lucky
my family old and new stuck by me
my board stuck by me my executive team
stuck by me and I have access to wildly
good health care I love my psychiatrist
I call him my most expensive friend
and I have and how many people have you
heard this from
I have medication that actually works
because of all that
all that support and all that
scaffolding I am able to live and love
and work with bipolar one
this shouldn't be a matter of luck
and so I've got one more crazy idea
maybe my craziest idea of all
we need to make mental health care
fundamentally acceptable
actually
[Music]
hang on this whole thing is going to
land great
actually affordable
and universally accessible
look I want us to be delusional
sometimes I want to be delusional
sometimes
I want people whose brains work
differently like mine does and like
yours might to be able to dream crazy
dreams to share crazy thoughts and God
willing or Universe willing bring those
dreams to life
but we have to keep ourselves in check
don't we
after all
only Messiahs are all-knowing
and entrepreneurs are not gods
even when we think we are
we will be better humans
building a better future together
when we take stock not just of how we
change the world
but how we treated each other and
ourselves along the way
and the president and Batman both agree
thank you